today I'm sneaking into a Renaissance
festival and a full suit of stormtrooper
armor and I'm telling you this is gonna
get crazy I only have three hours to
accomplish three tasks or else I have to
dress like Willy Wonka for a day my
three tasks are to get into the
Renaissance Festival even if I have to
sneak my way in find the king and queen
of the festival accomplish whatever
Quest they give me and do it all in
under three hours but first we have to
get into the festival and how might we
sneak our way in while wearing the
stormtrooper armor you ask by walking
through the front door I don't know if
anyone else has ever done this before so
it's a bit scary
okay that was easy that guy liked my
armor a bit too much little did I know
but my third task for the day would
actually result in me having to fight
for my life you guys are closed up yeah
okay next up find the king and queen you
want to take a picture or something yeah
but before I could even start my search
people started asking for pictures with
me
look at me I'm like a little celebrity
a long line of people was starting to
form so I had to get out of there the
Clock Was ticking and I needed to find
the king and queen
I just heard someone call me Darth Vader
who are you man people were starting to
take note of my armor and they seemed to
like it
holy cow
[Music]
what do you mean it's it's like
afternoon yeah
isn't isn't the yeah a little little
early I'm from a galaxy far far away a
long time ago so you probably haven't
even heard me there's a long time ago
when they realized they're on camera
they don't like it oh Ghostbusters
you're in the wrong place bud no this is
where we belong okay I found some
Ghostbusters but I need to find the king
and queen I'm running out of time
so bad I was starting to give up hope
that I'd be able to find them but then
this kid showed me how to swing around
his sword and it attracted some members
of the Royal Court
[Music]
I might never swings their swords
I always shoot without knowing where I'm
aiming I was finally pointed in the
exact right direction to find the king
and queen
not really no it's not very comfortable
or protective and I can't really see
much out of it I look you should ask
them to join our military oh how good is
your aim I won't be able to hit anything
okay all right um
get him
I said a chance against Amanda over here
is that best car
it's the best car I've got
there's a scoundrel amongst our court
the pirate king uh he's in a nice teal
outfit long gray curly hair I would look
for him I thought it's your command my
queen it is
I certainly will perfect I now knew what
my last task was and where to find the
pirate king so I decided to explore a
bit on my way to The Final Duel
starting yeah
[Applause]
in case you were wondering why
everyone's chanting for Joseph it's
because he was subscribed to my channel
and you should too
good question where did you two get your
armor
yes Amazon
shiny so yeah
I should never bring a sword to a
gunfight
that's probably nothing now that I had
settled my beef with the Knights it was
time to find the pirate king argue
which Queen I don't remember her name
honestly what is she wolf she said that
I was supposed to come and challenge you
to what I guess a duel or something oh
God I'll be there momentarily time
[Music]
in this pirate king
so are you challenging me
[Music]
all right I shall bring pistols
he uses a laser Blaster
no that's not fair guys
yes that's the Challenger you have the
right to choose your weapons no you
can't choose a laser weapon that's
cheating cheating I'll take this one all
right back to back
he wants a stormtrooper to win
[Music]
it was
got to be fair I could have given him a
whole gun he could have unloaded a whole
laser clip and missed it you lost I did
lose played badly it sucks that I lost
to the pirate king but it's not nearly
as bad as when I ran a 5K in the
stormtrooper armor even though he
cheated I wasn't able to accomplish the
last task within the time limit so it
looks like I'm gonna be living in a
purple coat and eating only candy for an
entire day